[Music]
let's take us all back to the election
trump was doing the ymca dance biden
couldn't even spell ymca
amy coney barrett sailing through and
warp speed was just around the corner
then of course you remember the october
surprise
the new york post aired hunter biden's
dirtiest laundry thanks to his lab top
from hell abandoned at a repair shop in
delaware now if you are watching this
channel you heard a lot about it that
was news
but if you were listening to the
mainstream media's russian style
propaganda courtesy of the biden
campaign
you were watching the biggest
disinformation campaign
almost in american history
on day one when the new york post broke
the story journalists
around the country swooped in to debunk
the laptop and all of the secrets that
lurked inside
they labeled it russian disinformation
fake news
articles like this were surfacing all
over
the truth behind the hunter biden's
non-scandal
was quick to pull the trigger at the
time she said quote the hunter biden
story is russian disinformation
they all sounded like parrots
annoying us with the same talking points
even cia officials
put out a letter claiming this couldn't
be true
who asked the cia anyway
anyone that reported on the laptop or
its contents was spreading
disinformation
and they were censored in america
not russia think about that
they even kicked the post off twitter
the country's oldest newspaper
they conspired and they lied
even hunter grabbed a mop and helped
with the cleanup job
was that your laptop for real i don't
know i know but you know that's this i
really don't know what the answer is you
don't know yes or no if the laptop i
don't have the idea i've no idea so it
could have been yours of course
certainly
there could be a laptop out there that
was stolen from me that could be that i
was hacked it could be that there was
that it was russian intelligence
the disinformation campaign was a huge
success
polls showing that one in six biden
voters would have changed their votes if
they had known about the laptop
so if you went through all of that
you'd be pretty surprised today when you
opened up the new york times
and peeled it open all the way back to
page 20 to see this headline quote
hunter biden paid tax bill but broad
federal investigation continues
is this the first time they've mentioned
the investigation into hunter's sketchy
business deals
the times reports that this all started
off with a tax audit under the obama
biden administration
and then it soon turned criminal when
his dad was running for president so
you're telling me that the obama biden
administration started looking into
biden's sons taxes
and biden's son never said anything to
his dad about it like hey dad why is
your irs auditing me
there's no way joe didn't know
and then your father's running for
president and the feds opened up a
criminal investigation into you for
money laundering and you don't pull your
dad aside and say hey pop
there's this little thing that may come
up during the campaign not a huge deal
but i'm kind of under investigation
of course hunter told joe that
joe knew the whole time the laptop was
real
and so did the new york times
hidden deep inside that article was an
admission quote
those emails were obtained by the new
york times from a cache of files that
appears to have come from a laptop
abandoned by mr biden in a delaware
repair shop the email and others in the
cash were authenticated by people
familiar with them
and with the investigation
so we were right about hunter being paid
three and a half million dollars
by a russian billionaire
so you're saying we were right about
hunter being given a three carat diamond
from a communist chinese businessman
three carrots it's a big rock when a man
gives another man a diamond
it's one of two things
an engagement or a bribe
now hunter's into some weird stuff so
we'll call it an indecent proposal
we were right about the fifty thousand
dollars a month he was making as a gas
expert working for burisma
and it hunter arranged for his dad to
meet with barisma lobbyists before he
fired the prosecutor we were right about
that
and if we're right about all of this
because the laptop has been proven real
by the paper of record
then that must mean
joe biden really is the big guy
and then it has 10 for the big guy held
by h
i a thousand percent sit here and know
that the big guy is referencing joe
biden um
it's that's crystal clear to me because
i lived it
and the big guy lied when he was running
for president listen
totally discredited and by the way well
wait he gets three and a half million
dollars joe mr vice president
that is not true my son did nothing
wrong at baristas
he doesn't want to let me answer because
he knows i have the truth his position
has been totally thoroughly described
by everybody well it's hard to get any
word in with this clown
so biden the democrats the intelligence
community and big tech lied and spread
dangerous misinformation to win an
election
and it gets worse if you can believe it
joe was knee-deep in hunter's finances
shared bank accounts credit cards paying
each other's bills with dirty foreign
money
the laptop and the emails confirm those
accusations
he was allegedly cutting 10 percent here
and there in exchange for secret
meetings with sketchy chinese
businessmen at the white house while he
was vice president
he took meetings at cafe milano in
washington
pretty good place
with some ukrainians and russians and
kazakhstani businessmen that hunter was
trying to strike up deals with
i met with the former vice president in
person
multiple times and i had been meeting
and talking with hunter biden and jim
biden and rob walker and james killier
oh
the biden brothers too
and joe
didn't have a problem with any of this
why woody his family was getting filthy
rich remember how smart hunter biden is
he's a grown man he is the smartest man
i know i mean for a pure intellectual
capacity
and
and as long as he's good we're good
joe says hunter is the smartest guy he
knows the smartest guy
wow
maybe that explains afghanistan and the
border and inflation and gas prices
here's what happened when jen saki was
asked about this story today
the new york times has authenticated
emails that appear to have come from a
laptop abandoned by hunter biden in
delaware
the president previously said that the
new york post story about this was a
bunch of garbage and that it was a
russian plant does he stand by that
assessment i appointed the department of
justice and also to hunter biden's
representatives he doesn't work in the
government
hunter doesn't work in government
yes he does it's the family business
hunter is the family lobbyist
excuse me hunter is also a very talented
painter
and if foreign agents want to spend
quarter mil to buy influence i mean a
painting from the first family well
the white house doesn't have a comment
if they do
it's probably just more disinformation
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else